- [Speaker 1] Alright, here we go.
(clicking sounds)
(upbeat music)
- My name's Matthew Mann.
I'm from Mississippi.
I'm just on here trying
to get a date, you know.
♪ Heard you say there's a high cop ♪
♪ But you left with a smile ♪
- I'm Jonah Goddard. I'm
from Chattanooga, Tennessee.
I'm trying to get a date with Grace.
She seems like a pretty sweet girl.
♪ Hello Grace ♪
♪ I wanna be your cop ♪
♪ I don't chase bears but ♪
So we just met today, but we're both
TikTokin' and Milly Rockin' all the time.
So that's how we know each other.
- You could be like, hello, Grace.
Da na na na na. Da na na na na na na.
- Yeah, but I gotta figure something out,
cause like it doesn't like
rhyme. Like back to back.
It ain't gotta rhyme
though. If it's gotta flow.
My boy, hey ain't no competition
when you both going for the same thing,
you know what I'm saying?
You supposed to support
each other out here.
You building up that good karma.
Can y'all move some lyrics?
So I can show him, like, the flow?
♪ Hello Grace ♪
♪ You were lookin' for Jeff ♪
♪ But I want to be your cop ♪
Da na na na na na.
You can make that work,
is what I'm saying.
Can you go back up to the top
and we're going to work down again.
- [Speaker 2] Just talk in there.
- Oh, talk in here?
♪ Hello Grace ♪
♪ You were looking for Jeff ♪
♪ But I want to be your cop. ♪
♪ Man I don't chase bears ♪
♪ But for you ♪
You just kind of see the flow
I'm going with, you got to
have the pause in between
it's going to meet the flow.
And I want us to sound good
because if he's on the same song with me.
If you both don't sound
good, you both sound bad.
- All right, let's do it.
- All right.
♪ Hello Grace ♪
♪ You were looking for Jeff ♪
♪ but I want to be your cop man ♪
♪ I don't chase bears ♪
♪ But for you ♪
♪ I would close my eyes ♪
♪ And chase that bear ♪
- I really appreciate you helping me, man.
- My boy.
♪ I want to show you that I care. ♪
♪ First things first ♪
♪ I'd still chase the bear ♪
♪ Not gonna lie ♪
(crowd cheering)
- Oh my gosh! Oh my gosh!
- Cause if the date don't end up working,
then we're gonna have a hit song.